tous les fans de david bowie ne sont pas
des fixies la preuve rappelle natacha
comme son nom l'indiqué elle est
d'origine russe
elle est née au tout début du siècle
elle habite actuellement dans le 15e
arrondissement à paris natacha a
rencontré david bowie en 1964 depuis
c'est devenu une fan inconditionnelle
ramon gutierrez est allé lui rendre
visite aujourd'hui dans son petit
appartement de la rue de l'amiral roues
ce que je vais vous la mafia loge 77 78
3 9g de la doyenne des amis de
lille-bouvines 92,5 est fan de huit
grossistes injustement et ça qu'il a
converti son mari
pas tout à fait
vous avez sa musique venue qu'est-ce que
vous visitez les choses solides mais
c'est bien portants sais je ne pensais
pas sur le vélo je suis trop bien pour
danser
oui vous l'avez rencontré david bowie
oui messieurs
à quelle occasion la première fois qu'un
club
on en reste à mes amis ma vérité nous a
mis en grève quand il passait en martyr
que leur message était tout à fait c'est
dire donc j'avais senti que c'était un
artiste au il te fait all in avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé beaucoup d'âmes
n'essaie pas d'en faire ce qu'il faut
c'est ça qui nous fait l'artiste sansa
savez c zéro en attente de chanteurs qui
intime tout parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'épreuve
je veux aussi vous voir aussi llodra son
concert à paris je t'invite et vos
concerts jeux propres y revit et sa
secrétaire a insisté mourinho cherche je
serai donc mais oui faut mieux clichés
jeffrey rosen pour cette foule énorme
et puis tous les bruits qui va presque
précipitée alors m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient plusieurs sorties c'est pas
grave de voir toute cette jeunesse
autour de vous le donne en mille
je ne peux pas le jeunesse vous la
recherchez oublier bien sûr comme je
n'ai pas l'esprit chagrin